14 year old high school student arrested
for bringing a homemade clock to school
a South Jersey fifth grader is suspended
from bringing a toy to school it's that
picture the thoughts in a stick team
drew of a bomb from the game that hasn't
suspended until further notice this son
also said the words
bang bang while holding that breakfast
pastry rolling into school with the
deadly device and every person in my
path better take my advice cuz if I ever
draw my weapon you'll be praying to
Christ and if you dare to double-cross
me son you're gonna get iced I'm busting
into your crib got the basement lack
packing super deadly weapons like a
makeshift clock you're gonna be hiding
tonight pulling up your covers keeping
one eye open like you're sleeping let
the juggernaut a finger gun oh wait I
got another waving bye-bye as I Drive my
brother taking dead aim it's about to
get Cory Wayne fender scared of fingers
is the time you turn forward cuz it's
over you lost and now it's early
retirement like Keith Olbermann's bosses
all I'm doing this by shotguns never
been deadlier most deadly by far you can
call in the front seat up in kennedy's
car because I'm dangerous
there ain't no debating this killing
people like a VA hospital waiting list
and that my magic ring it's gonna do
wonders make you disappear like Scott
Walker's pull numbers
the manufacturer of the weapon that is a
good question it was believed Smith and
Wesson spent I'm sorry Little Debbie
[Music]
you